Evet, merhaba değerli insan. Geldik
neredeyiz? 1. ünitemizin artık son
kısmındayız. Bitirmemiz gerekiyor. Çok
önemli kısımlardan bahsedeceğim bu
dersimizde. Laboratuvar güvenlik
kuralları çok çok önemlidir. Bazı
kimyasalların zararlı ve yararlı
kimyasalların işte ne olduğundan
bahsedeceğiz. Bunlar elementler,
bileşikler, farklı türleri var. Bunların
detaylarından bahsedeceğiz. Sonra
laboratuvar güvenlik işaretleri var. Bu
tahriş edici falan filan. Bunlardan
bahsedeceğim. Bir de laboratuvar
aletleri var. Bunları tek tek göstermeye
çalışacağım. Elimde olduğu kadarıyla
sana canlı olarak da göstermeye
çalışacağım. Yani bu derste birazcık
böyle kimyayla haşır neşır olacağız. O
zaman vakit kaybetmeyelim ama onun
öncesinde bir hatırlatma yapıyorum. Ne
yapıyorsun? Kanala abone oluyorsun.
Arkadaşlarına tavsiye ediyorsun. Arada
bir de yorum yapıp beğenirsen kaymaklı
ekmek kadayıfı olur. Çok mutlu olurum.
Zedua ile eğitim her yerde. Başlayalım.
Şimdi güzel insan. Aha dur kalemimi
alayım. Şu an masadaki malzemeleri
görsem var ya üf dünya kadar malzeme var
şu anda. Onların hepsini elimden
geldiğince göstereceğim. Laboratuvar
güvenlik kuralları dediğimizde neler
vardır? Bir kere bir deneye başlamadan
önce ne yapman gerekiyor? Deneyle ilgili
notları okuman gerekiyor. Yani hangi
deney yapacaksın oğlum? Yani orada
deneyde kullanacağın malzemeler ne?
Nelere dikkat etmen gerekiyor? Hepsini
okuman gerekiyor. Yani deneyle ilgili
bilgi sahibi olmadan başlanmaz. Yani
simyacı değilsin, sınama yanılmayla
yapmıyorsun. Hepsini belli bir prosedüre
uydurarak yapman gerekiyor. Bundan
dolayı dostum o deney föyünü okuman
gerekiyor. Devam edelim. Sorumlu
öğretmenin gözetimi dışında, gözetiminin
dışında hiçbir şekilde işlem yapmamak
gerekiyor. Onun bilgisi dışında hiçbir
şeye dokunmamak gerekiyor. Ki bununla
ilgili daha önce de anlatmıştım. Bir
tane öğrencim bunu yapmıştı. Biz orada
deneye yoğunlaşmışız. Herkes toplanmış.
Öyle işlemeye çalışıyoruz. Bak şu
şöyledir, bu böyledir falan. Sen arka
tarafta git bir tane bunzembeki diye
daha doğrusu bunzembeki değil ispirto
ocağını al. Ama ispirto ocağı da
arızalı. Benim hatam şu onu orada
bırakmamam gerekiyordu. Ona hemen atmam
gerekiyordu. Ama atılacaklar kısmını
ayırmışım. Orada duruyor. Sen git bunu
al, yak bunu. Yaktıktan sonra da işte
ispirto içinde ısınıyor, ısınıyor,
ısınıyor. Arızalı dedim ya. Tam böyle
deney yaparken pat diye bir cam kırılma
sesiyle beraber bir alev yükseldi. La
dedim ne oluyor? Kafayı bir çevirdim.
Arka taraftaki masada, masa böyle
yanmaya başlamış. Birkaç tane de ya masa
Allah'tan şey eee nasıl söyleyeyim?
Üzeri cam vardı da hani bir sıkıntı
olmuyor ama dökülmüş. Boş sandalyelerde
falan böyle tutuşma başlamıştı. Hemen
bezleri ıslatıp üzerini kapattık. Ondan
sonra işte şeylerle işte yangın
söndürücü falan filan o şeyleri
söndürdük, kurtardık. İkiü tane
sandalyeye mal oldu. Ama çocuğun elleri
gidiyordu az kalsın. Çünkü o patlamayla
beraber elleri alev aldı. İspirto eline
döküldü. Eli alev aldı. Eldiven vardı.
Dedim, "Sıyır at eldivenleri." Hemen
eldivenleri sıyırda attı. Çok şükür
ellerini kurtardı. Herhangi bir yanık
oluşmadı. O korku yetti ona zaten. Ama
tabii ki diğer öğrenciler korktu falan.
Ondan sonra neyse deneyi bitirdik
çıktık. Yani orada gözetmen, öğretmen
kimse onun sözünün dışına çıkmamak
gerekiyor. Onun sözünün dışında bir şeye
de dokunmamak gerekiyor. Aa bu neymiş
falan. Dokunma arkadaş. Tehlikeli.
Hocana sor. Hocan müsaade ederse dokun.
Devam ediyorum. Ne var işte başka?
Kimyasal maddelerle ısıtma ve karıştırma
işlemlerinde ne yapmak gerekiyor?
Kimsenin yüzüne tutmamak gerekiyor.
Kiçmiş yıllarda böyle bir olay
yaşanmıştı. Bir eee deney sırasında bir
okulda yaşanmıştı bu. Böyle eğik tutuyor
tüpü. Şöyle tüp. Dur bakayım nerede var
mı lan? Var. Şöyle bir tüp mesela. Bu
tüpü eğik tutuyor. İçinde kimyasal var.
Burada bir sıçrama yapıyor. Bir patlama
yapıyor. Çocuğun yüzüne gelmişti galiba.
Gözünün birini kaybetmişti çocuk. Yani
doğrudan asla insan yüzüne tutulmaması
gerekiyor. Açık da bir yere tutulması
gerekiyor. Başka mümkünse çeker ocak
altında çalışmak gerekiyor. Çeker ocak
dediğimiz o gazları şunları bunları
çeken özel bir ortamdır. Orada çalışmak
gerekiyor. O yüzden hiçbir böyle yanıcı,
parlayıcı, böyle patlayıcı maddeleri
insan yüzüne doğru tutmamak gerekiyor.
Kimyasal maddeler buharlaşabileceğinden
dolayı tam olarak söylediğim ifade işte
çeker ocak yani bir çeşit aspiratör
altında çalışmak gerekiyor. Satıcılar
kullanıldıktan sonra işlem bitti ya.
Bittikten sonra fişini çekmen lazım.
Unuttun. E sıkıntı yani değil mi?
Laboratuvarı yakma ihtimalin var. O
fişleri çekeceksin. Başka? Kimyasal
maddeler doğrudan koklanmamalı ve
kesinlikle tadına bakılmamalı ki bunu
ben her laboratuvar dersinden önce
yapıyordum. Önce laboratuvar güvenlik
kurallarını öğretiyordum. Laboratuvar
güvenlik kurallarını öğrettikten sonra
laboratuvara iniyoruz. Ben bir tane
çözelti hazırlıyordum oraya. eee amonyak
çözeltisi ama seyreltik amonyak
çözeltisini hazırlıyordum. Koyuyordum
öyle içinde sıvı böyle rengi su gibi
gözüküyor. Orada duruyor. İçinde ne
olduğunu bilmiyorsun değil mi? Birçok
öğrenci şu hareketi yapıyordu. Alıyordu.
Bu ne hocam? Şu bak hemen koklama ya. Ne
var oğlum? Ne kokluyorsun bunu? Koklar
koklamaz tabii ki. Amonyak kokusu
birden. Gözlerin böyle şey olur.
Yerinden fırlar yani. Çok kötüdür işte.
Öğreticidir ama bir daha yapmaz o insan.
Peki içinde ne olduğunu bilmiyorsan
nasıl koklarsın? Koklama şekli şudur
bak. Alırsın karşına şöyle tutarsın. Şu
hareketi yaparsın. Şöyle yaptığında
zaten içindeki koku gelir. Kötüyse zaten
itmeye başlarsın. Yani aklında olsun.
İçinde ne olduğunu bilmiyorsan doğrudan
koklanmaz. Önce şöyle yaparak kokunun ne
olduğunu hafif bir şekilde anlarsın. Ona
göre bakarsın. Ha güzel koku. Ona göre
bakarsın. Tadına zaten asla bakmaman
gerekiyor. Zehirli oğlum ya. Tehlikeli
şeyler bunlar. Heh. Geldik buraya devam
ediyoruz. Laboratuvarda yiyecek ve
içecek bulundurulmamalıdır. Bunun da
sebeplerinden bir tanesi şudur.
Buharlaşabilen, süblimleşebilen yani
sonuçta ortamda kimyasal madde
bulunabiliyor ve gıdanın üzerine
dökülebilir. Gıdanın üzerine
yapışabilir. Bu da tehlikeli bir
durumdur. Yapmamak lazım. Giyilen
kıyafetler laboratuvarda çalışmaya uygun
olmalıdır. Böyle çok bol veya çok açık
olmaması gerekiyor. Hocam kıyafete mi
karışıyorsunuz? Ya laboratuvarda
karışıyorum arkadaş. Tabii ki
karışıyorum. Düşünsene çok açık
olduğunda bir şey sıçrasa üstüne çok
tehlikeli. Yani o önlük giyeceksin, şunu
bunu yapacaksın. E önlükte her yeri
kapatmıyor. E haliyle laboratuvarda
birazcık böyle kapalı giyinmen
gerekiyor. Çünkü sıçrama şubu çok
tehlikelidir. Onun dışında başka çok bol
da giyinemezsin. Bol giyindin. E bir
şeye dokundun hop devirdin. Değil mi?
Yani bunların ihtimalidir. Veya işte
şeyler takılar şunlar bunlar kolundan
şuradan buradan sarkıyor. Değdin,
döktün. Bunların hepsi tehlikelidir.
Yani laboratuvarda bu tip şeylere dikkat
etmek gerekiyor. Laboratuvara uygun
giyinmek gerekiyor. Kapalı ayakkabı
giymen gerekiyor. Kimyasal dökülmesin
diye. Yani laboratuvara giriyorsan
birazcık sağın solun kapalı olmak
zorunda. Çünkü tehlikeli. Bir diğeri
mesela pipet kullanırken diyor ya pipet
kullanırken kesinlikle ağızla
çekilmemeli. Puar kullanılmalı. Hemen
gösteriyorum güzel insan. Aha da pipet
dediğimiz şey şu. Pipet bu. Bununla sıvı
çekiliyor ya. Bununla sıvı çekilirken
kullanılan alet şudur. Poar dediğimiz
alet. Bunu şöyle takarsın. Şu tepesine.
Şunu şöyle şurada bir şey var. Tepesini
sıkıp bastığında. Basamadım lan. Dur.
Nasıl basılıyordu bu? Dur lan.
Yapamadım. Heh. Aha. Şöyle bastın ya.
Şöyle çukur oluşuyor. Şöyle çukur
oluşuyor. Sıvının içerisine
daldırıyorsun. Sıvının içerisine
daldırdıktan sonra şuradaki düğmeye
hafif bastığında ne oluyor? Yükselmeye
başlıyor. Dur göstereceğim onu. Heh.
Şöyle bak. Şişti. Gördün mü? Bu şekilde
yükselmeye başlıyor. Sıvı. Sen buraya
bastıkça içinde yükseliyor. Ondan sonra
diğerine basarak da sıvı içinde
alçalıyor. Yani hiç tehlikeli durum
olmadan şu puarla bütün o sıvıyı çekme
ve alçaltma işlemini, dökme işlemini
yapıyorsun. İşte bizim üniversitede bir
tane arkadaş Kadir diye bir arkadaşım
vardı. Deney yapıyoruz. Hidroklorik
asitle deney yapıyoruz. Aha böyle
daldırdı içine. Şöyle çekiyor. Sanki
milk şey geçiyor yani. Tehlikeli şey
yapılmaz. Bak şu şekilde hidroklorik
asit var. Seyreltik de Allah'tan. şöyle
yapıyor. Şu şekilde çekiyor. Bak bunu
yaparken sıvının böyle tam üzerine denk
gelmiş. Ben de böyle yaptım. O sırada
bir şey mi sormuştum? Bilerek de yapmış
olabilirim. Ben biraz manyağımdır. Kadir
dedim böyle yaptı. Efendim dedi. Bununla
beraber çekince boşluk oldu. Hop asit
ağzına kaçtı. Hidroklorik asit Allah'tan
ilk başta sızlatır. Böyle direkt ağzı
haşat etmez. Ama çok canı yandı. Bayağı
bir küfür yemiştim. Akşama kadar
kovalamıştı beni. Yani böyle bir olayda
yaşamıştım. Bunu daha önce de
anlatmıştım mesela. Yani böyle ağızla
çekmemek gerekiyor. Puar kullanmak
gerekiyor. Kimyasal ne olursa olsun
tehlikeli bir şey bu. Şimdi devam ettim.
Diyor ki yanıcı maddelerin yakınında
alev olmamasına dikkat edilmelidir. Yani
değil mi? Sonuç olarak demin anlattığım
olaydaki gibi işte. Ne olabilir? İşte o
ispirtoyla çalışıyor. E ne oldu? Yanıcı
madde var alt tarafta. Üstte yanıyor.
Patlama oldu. Her tarafa yangın yayıldı.
Değil mi? Tehlikeli bir şey işte. Başka
ne var? Sıçrama olabilecek tüm
deneylerde koruyucu gözlük takılmalı.
Nasıl bir şeyden bahsediyorum? Aha da
böyle bir şeyden bahsediyorum. Koruyucu
gözlük şu. Şuraları şöyle açıyorsun. Şu
şekilde işte bunu çıkarıp mesela bunu
takıyorsun. Allah'tan benim koruyucu
gözlüğüm var. Bir tane var. Ben bazen
göremediğim için bunun üzerine böyle
takıyordum. Tabii saçma oluyor da yani
bunu taktığında bak bunun özelliği şu.
Şu şekilde taktığında yanları koruyor.
Şu şekilde yanları koruyor. E buralar
yüksek. Şurası kapalı. O yüzden göz
bölgesini ciddi şekilde koruyor. Ha tam
yüz maskeleri de var. Tam yüz maskesi.
Onu da göstermek istiyorum size. E bir
dakika şunu şöyle bırakayım. Aha şu
şekilde tam yüz maskeleri de bulunmakta.
Şöyle bu bu kolay. Şunu alıyorsun kafana
yerleştiriyorsun. Tabii çok sıkı olmuş.
He. Şöyle yerleştiriyorsun. Şu şekilde.
Bak şöyle yaptığında ne olmuş oluyor?
Tamamen korumuş oluyor. Bu bir yöntem.
Saçları da bozduk la. Dur lan o nasıl
oldu öyle? Heh. Tamam. Bir de bu var. Bu
daha da güzel. Şunu bırakalım. Bunu
şöyle şey gibi şu şekilde tepeden
takıyorsun. Bu neye benziyor? Bu işte
Breaking Bad'deki var ya eee çeşitli
çalışmalar yaptığında kullandığı e şeye
benziyor. İşte bu da tam yüz maskesi.
Ayriyeten zaten filtresi falan da var.
Maske. Tam tam maske. Bu işte en iyi
koruyucu kimyasal maskelerinden bir
tanesidir. Evet. Saçı başı toparlıyorum.
Devam ediyorum. Hop geldim buraya. Çok
güzel. Deneylerden sonra kullanılan
eşyalar mutlaka temizlenip
kaldırmalıdır. Eğer temizlemeden
kaldırırsan ne oluyor biliyor musun? Bir
sonraki deney için geldi diyelim birisi
ve o deneyde kullanılan malzemenin temiz
olduğunu zannetti. İçerisine bir
kimyasal kattı. Şansa da senin daha önce
bıraktığın deneydeki kimyasalla o
tepkimeye girip patlayabilir, riskli
veya yangın çıkabilir. Böyle bir şey de
yaşamıştık. Çok ilginçtir. Biz işte
şeylere geri dönüşüme atıyoruz. Geri
dönüşüm demişim işte kimyasal eee atık
kısmını atıyoruz. Ben deneyi yaptım işte
bıraktım. bir hata işte o da bir
hatadır. Eee, bir şey oldu. Böyle bir
peçete üzerinde deneyip temizledikten
sonra onu da gittim normal çöpe attım.
Bu hatadır. Normal onu işte
kimyasalların olduğu yere atmak
gerekiyordu. Benden sonra gelen hoca da
deney sırasında bir başka bir deney
yapıyor. O da temizliyor. Fakat o şeyi
de diğer kimyasalı da atıyor çöpe. Atar
atmaz benim attığımla o tepkimeye
giriyor. Neydi? Hidrojen peroksit galiba
atıyor. Hidrojen peroksitte ıslanmış bir
peçeteyi atıyor. Benim attığım da şeydi
galiba. E potasyum permanganattı. Bunlar
tepkimeye giriyor. E tepkime
gerçekleşince çöpte bu bakıyor. Böyle
bir ufak alev gerçekleşiyor. He diyor
ulan bir şey oldu falan. Hemen yangın
söndürücüyle müdahale ediyorlar ama
sonra bana sordun. Ne yaptın dedi. Dedim
ben bunu yaptım. He dedi benim hatam
dedi. Ben çöpe atınca dedi orada tepkime
oldu. Yani böyle riskli şeyler var. O
yüzden kimyasal atıkları kimyasal
kısımlarına yani kimyasal atık
depolarına bırakman gerekiyor. Onun
dışında kullandığın malzemeleri
temizlemen gerekiyor. Bu önemli bir
detaydır. Bir diğeri ise sıvı
kimyasallar yüksekte değil zemine yakın
tutulma. Niye yüksekte olursa alırken
devirebilirsin. Tehlikeli bir kimyasal
olabilir. Üzerine dökülebilir. O yüzden
zemine yakın olursa daha iyi olacak.
Başka ne var? Kimyasal maddelerin
üzerindeki uyarılar dikkate alınmalıdır.
O da hemen göstereyim sana bir tane
örnek göstereyim. Mesela potasyum
permanganat. Bu işte üzerinde şöyle
uyarı işaretleri bulunmakta. Ne bu? İşte
tahriş edici, aşındırıcı ve yakıcı
uyarıları var mesela. Demek ki bununla
çalışırken bu uyarılara dikkat etmek
gerekiyor. Daha birçok şey var. Kimyasal
var. Onlara işte o uyarılarına dikkat
ederek de zaten depolaman gerekiyor.
Onun dışında başka ne var? Heh, çok
önemli bir şey. Şuna böyle yıldızı
atıyorum. Bu neredeyse bu konuyla
alakalı soru çıktığında hep şıklardan
bir tanesinde olur. Asidin üzerine su
dökülmez. Suyun üzerine yavaşça asit
dökülerek seyreltme yapılır. Bu çok
önemlidir. Asla ve asla asidin üzerine
su dökmemek lazım. Sıçrama yapabilir.
Çok tehlikelidir. Başka ne var? Uçucu,
yanıcı, çözücü maddeler sebebiyle
pillerin alev alma riski bulunduğu için
laboratuvarda cep telefonu
kullanılmamalıdır. Cep telefonlarıyla
bazı uçucu kimyasallar işte oksitlenme
falan yapıp orada eee ne yapabilir? Şase
mi diyorlar? Bir şey kısa devre e
diyorlar. Kısa devre yapıp telefonun
patlamasına sebep bile olabilir. Ya
düşük bir risk ama sonuçta olmayacak bir
risk değil. Dikkat etmek lazım. Kırık,
çatlak ve kirli cam malzeme
kullanılmamalıdır. Bu da önemli bir
detay. İşte bu laboratuvar güvenlik
kurallarından sonra laboratuvar güvenlik
işaretleri var. Mesela birincisi ne
olmuş? Bak şöyle yaklaştım. Bir el
işareti var. Ne oluyor? Üzerine işte bir
şeyler damlıyor. Bu ney? Korozif ya da
aşındırıcı dediğimiz işaret. Göz, cilt
ve diğer dokularla temasında aşındırıcı
etki gösterir. Metal cam ve kumaş
üzerinde de aşındırıcı etkiye sahiptir
demektir bu. Mesela sodyum hidroksitin
üzerinde bu olabilir. Sülfürik asidin
üzerinde bulunabilir. O da burada mesela
bak sülfürik asidin üzerinde bu işaret
bulunuyor. Şöyle heh göstersin. Ne
tarafta? Şurada bak görüyor musun?
Ortadaki işaret mesela. Onu birazdan
zaten yakından da göstereceğim. Fenol,
hidroklorik asit bunların üzerinde
bulunmakta. Başka ne varmış? Patlayıcı.
Patlayıcı alev, kıvılcım ve ısınma gibi
etkilerle patlamaya sebep olan
maddelerin üzerinde olmalı.
Nitrogliserin, dinamit gibi. Allah'tan
bunlar elde olan bir şeyler değil. Başka
ne var? Tahriş edici. Tahriş edici
işareti ya ünlem şeklinde gösterilir ya
da eskiden olduğu gibi şöyle çarpı
şeklinde de gösterilebiliyor. Tahriş
edici, bazen zararlı da diyorlar ama
yok. Buna tahriş edici diyoruz. Cilt,
göz ve solunum yollarında tahrişe neden
olan kızarıklıklara falan sebep olur. Bu
birçok evdeki temizlik maddesinin
üzerinde bu işaret vardır. Mesela çarpı
şeklinde olan veya ünlem şeklinde olan
çamaşır suyu, etil alkol, deterjan.
Birçok kimyasalda bu bulunmakta.
döküldüğü yeri böyle kızarıklığa sebep
olur. Tahriş edici etkisi vardır
diyoruz. Bir diğeri bu yanıcı
işaretidir. Kolonyanın üzerinde falan
görürsün veya asetonun üzerinde
görebilirsin. Kızlar ojeyi
çıkarıyorsunuz ya onun üzerinde bu
bulunacaktır. Bakayım var mı benim
elimde öyle bir şey? Şu anda masada yok.
Göremedim. Heh. Tutuşma sıcaklığı düşük
olup kolay yanabilen ve yandığında zor
söndürülebilen maddeleri ifade
etmektedir. Alkol, aseton gibi tam
olarak söylediğim örnekler. Bu da yakıcı
işareti ya da oksitleyici işareti. Bu
yanıcı maddelerle temas ettiğinde
yanmaya sebep olan bir şeydir. Yani bu
temas sonucunda yanma oluşabilir ki şu
an onu getirmedim. O içeride ondan
tırsıyorum niye başka ne var? Hno var.
Başka H2O2 hidrojen peroksiti göstermiş.
Oksijen, klor gibi örnekler. Hatta benim
elimde potasyum permanganat var ki
yaklaşarak göstereyim. Bak üzerinde
şöyle işaret duruyor. Bak gördün mü?
Şurada oksitleyici işareti gözüküyor.
Oksitleyici ile yanıcıyı ayırt etmenin
yolu O harfi. Bak O harfi burada ayırt
edicidir. Bir tane daha göstermek
istiyorum. Potasyum klorat mesela.
Potasyum kloratta da aynı şekilde o
işaret bulunmakta. Yan tarafında da
çevreye zararlı. Bu tarafında da bak
gördün mü? Tahriş ediciyi çarpı şeklinde
göstermiş. Birazcık bu kutu eski galiba.
Onu da zaten ne zamandır kullanmıyordum.
Herhalde atarım büyük ihtimalle kimyasal
şeyine, deposuna. Ivit. Devam ediyorum.
Dur. Heh. Yanlış şey aldık. O geldik
buraya. Bu ne? Zehirli işareti. Ağız,
deri ve solunum yolu ile zehirlenmelere
yol açabilen maddelerdir. Ne bu?
Hidrojen sülfür var, metil amin var,
hidrojen siyanür, potasyum siyanür gibi
maddeler. Ki şu potasyum siyanür birkaç
sene önce bir eee şey vardı. Bir olay
yaşanmıştı. Trajik bir olaydı. Ailesine
eee ne yazık ki böyle bir şey yapıyor.
Ölümle sonuçlanmıştı. Allah vermesin.
Kötü bir şey. Tehlikelidir. Siyanür
ölümleri çok da böyle acı vericidir.
Kesinlikle ve kesinlikle bu kimyasaldan
uzak durmak lazım. Başka ne var?
Ekotoksik ya da diğer ismiyle çevreye
zararlı. Demin göstermişim işte bir ölü
balık var, ölü ağaç var. Yani çok basit
bir şekilde anlaşılabiliyor. Bu çevreye
ve insan sağlığına zararlı maddeleri
ifade eder ki bütün kimyasallar aşağı
yukarı bu özelliğe sahiptir diyebilirim.
Yani birçok kimyasalda bu özellik
mevcuttur diyoruz. E bu zaten radyoaktif
uyarı işareti ki bunu nerede görüyorsun
daha çok? İşte hastanelerde falan
radyasyon uyarısı işareti vardır. Film
çekilirken falan denk gelmişsindir. Yani
evde çok da denk geleceğin bir şey değil
bu. Ama mesela uranyum, röntgen cihazı
bunlar da bulunmakta. E bende bir tane
şey var. İçerisinde gerçek elementlerin
olduğu bir tane periyodik tablo var.
Orada şey çok küçük miktarda bir şey
var. Uranyum var. Ama ondan da bir şey
olmaz zaten. Bak ÖSYM buna benzer bir
soru sormuştu. diyor ki bir kimyasal
madde şişesi üzerinde sadece aşağıdaki
sağlık ve güvenlik uyarı işaretleri
bulunmaktaymış diyor. Çok güzel. Buna
göre bu madde ile ilgili aşağıdakilerden
hangisi doğrudur? Bu neydi? Eli böyle
şey yapıyor, deliyor değil mi? He bu
neydi? Aşındırıcı ya da korozif
diyorduk. Korozif. Korozif ya da
aşındırıcı. Bu da olur. Şuna
baktığımızda bu neydi? Ortada O harfi
var. Görüyorsun. Oksitleyici ya da
yakıcı ismini veriyorduk. Yakıcı. Tamam.
Bu ne? Yanıcı dediği için olmaz.
Patlayıcı dediği için olmaz. Cevabım ne
oldu? A seçeneği oldu. Mesela burada
diyor ki, "Aşağıdaki laboratuvar
güvenlik piktogramlarından." piktogram
da denir buna. Hangisinin adı yanlıştır?
E bu yanıcıydı. Bu zehirliydi ya da
toksik diyorduk. E bu ne oluyordu? Bu
tahriş ediciydi. Ünlem ya da çarpı
şeklinde gösteriyordu. Korozif olan bu
ele bir şeyler döküldüğü görüntüydü.
Yani korozifin görüntüsü şu dostum. Yani
o değil. Tahriş ediciyle korozif çok
karıştırılır. Dikkat etmekte fayda var.
Yanlışı bulduk. Cevap C. Evet. Patlayıcı
uyarı işareti. Bu da çevreye zararlı
oluyor dostum. Şimdi günlük hayatta
karşılaştığımız bazı maddeler var ki
bunların yararlı olanları var, zararlı
olanları var ki mesela sodyumdan
bahsedelim. Sodyum aslında vücut için
yararlı. Bunun iyon hali vücut için
gerçekten faydalıdır. Vücuttaki su
dengesinin korunmasını sağlamaktadır.
Besinlerin hücre duvarından geçişini
kolaylaştırır. Kas ve sinir
fonksiyonlarının sağlıklı bir şekilde
çalışmasında görev alır ki vücutta bunu
e biosemsemi hocam size anlatacak. Ne
vardı? şeyden bahsediyor. Sodyum
potasyum dengesi vardır bu sinir
iletiminde. Yani sodyum kesinlikle vücut
için gerekli bir şeydir. Diyor ki vücut
sıvılarının nötrlük düzeyinin
korunmasında görev alır. Toprak ve iyon
dengesini sağlar. Yani bu kısım bak şu
kısım şimdi anlatacağım kısım birazcık
böyle genel kültür gibidir. ÖSYM'nin az
soru sorduğu bir yerdir ama en azından
bir kere okumakta fayda var dostum.
Devam edelim. Mesela potasyumdan
bahsedelim. Potasyum sodyuma göre daha
yumuşak bir metaldir ve vücuttaki
sıvıların iyon dengesinin ve
yoğunluğunun korunmasında görev
almaktadır. Aynı şekilde sinir iletimi
için lazımdır. Sinir sinir işlevlerinin
çalışmasında, hormonların kontrolünde
gerekiyor. Kandaki glikoz düzeyinin
düzenlenmesinde faydalıymış. Topraktaki
iyon dengesini ve bitkilerin büyümesi
için gerekliymiş. Zaten makrobesin mi
diye geçiyordu? Öyle bir şeydi galiba.
Bunun böyle bir ismi de vardı. Sonra
geldik demir. Demir zaten dediğin anda
ne oluyor? Hemoglobin. Bak hemoglobin
hemoglobinin yapısında bulunmaktadır.
Yani kana kırmızı rengine veren
hemoglobinde demir bulunmaktadır.
Oksijen taşımamızda zaten hemoglobinin
oksijen taşımasında demir görev
yapmaktadır. Çok önemlidir. Başka ne
var? DNA sentezinde rol almaktadır.
Beynin normal çalışması için gereklidir.
He demek ki bazılarında bayağı bir demir
eksikliği. Neyse. Evet devam ediyorum.
Kalsiyuma baktığımızdaysa kalsiyum
kemiklerin ana bileşenidir. Diyeceksin
ya hocam kalsiyum böyle mi gözüküyor?
Evet. Bak metalik hali budur. Ama biz
genellikle o beyaz şey halini biliyoruz.
Kemikteki görüntüsünü biliyoruz. E
iskelet ve kas sistemi için kalsiyum
olmazsa olmazdır. Çok değerlidir.
Metabolik fonksiyonların yönetimi için
gereklidir. Sinir ve kasların işlevinde
işlevine yani çalışmasına yardımcı
olmaktadır. Magnezyumdan bahsedelim ki
bu da kemik ve kasların yapısında
bulunmakta. kasların ve sinirlerin
gelişmesinde görev almaktadır. Ki şöyle
bir şeydir. Doğal stres önleyici derken
magnezyum gerçekten çok değerli bir
mineraldir. Vücut için gereklidir. Hatta
çeşitleri var. Magnezyum, laktat falan
filan böyle bir sürü türleri var. Her
birinin ayrı bir görevi var.
Instagram'da zaten karşına çıkmıştır
garanti. Bununla ilgili şunu bilmek
lazım. Magnezyum eksikliğinde bazen
şöyle bir şey olur. Gözün seyir,
vücudunda bir yerin böyle titrer, kasın
titrer falan filan. İşte bu titremeler,
seyirmeler magnezyum eksikliğinden
kaynaklanmaktadır. O yüzden arada bir
böyle magnezyum oranı yüksek maden suyu
içmekte fayda vardır. Veya işte
magnezyum tabletleri yani bir şekilde
vücuttaki magnezyum depolarını doldurman
gerekiyor. Heh. Başka? Ayrıca enzimlerin
yapısında, adrenalin hormonunun
salgılanmasında, kanın pıhtılaşmasında
ki çok önemli bir görevdir. Nedir? Görev
alır diyoruz dostum. Su yani suyu
söylemeye gerek yok. çok değerlidir.
Vücudumuzun ve dünyanın büyük kısmı
sudan oluşmaktadır. Hücrelerin yaşamsal
faaliyetleri ve vücut fonksiyonlarının
yerine getirilmesinde lazımdır. Günlük
ortalama olarak 2-2,5 litrelik su
tüketimi çok değerlidir. İnsan vücudu
için gereklidir. En büyük yaptığımız
hata ki bunu da ne yazık ki ben de bazen
yapıyorum. Aa susadığımda su içiyorum.
Ya susamak şudur aslında. Vücudun alarm
sistemidir. Yani artık la su lazım bana
diyor. Su lazım. O yüzden susadığında
değil. Yani bunu ilaç niyetine gün
içerisinde 2,5 litre içecek şekle
getirmek gerekiyor. Yani suyu illa
susadığında değil normalde de içmen
lazım. Vücut susadığında artık iyice
sınıra gelmiş demektir. Mümkün mertebe o
suyu eksik etmemek lazım. Ama bazen şu
hata yapılıyor. İşte alıyor suyu bir
diyor ki ben 1,5 litrelik suyu içeceğim.
Akşam oturuyor tek seferde içiyor.
Olmaz. Gün içerisine yayman gerekiyor su
içme işini. Tek seferde içersen anında
böbrek hop aşağıya vuracak. Ondan sonra
zaten kolbastı oynamaya başlıyorsun
değil mi? Sıkışınca hele bir de
tuvalette biri varsa Allah yardım etsin.
Yani birden içmeyeceksin. Güne
yayacaksın. Tamam mı? O çok önemli.
Fazla veya az su tüketimi kesinlikle
vücudun elektrolit dengesi için
tehlikelidir. Çok su içmek de iyi değil.
Bir tane şey vardı. Neydi teyze?
Damacanayla içiyordu. Lakır lıkır
içiyor. Sinir bir sesle. Çok şükür falan
filan şeyi var ya böyle kavanozla mı
içiyordu? Bir şeyle içiyordu ya. O da
abartı da yani işte aradaki dengeyi
tutturmak lazım hücrelere. Tabii ki
besinlerin taşınmasında, vücuttaki
biyokimyasal olayların gerçekleşmesinde
su kesinlikle lazım. Su bizim yaşam
kaynağımız. Bunlar yararlılardı. Peki
zararlı maddeler var mı? Var. Kurşun
mesela çevre kirliliği oluşturur. Kurşun
zehirlenmesine sebep olur. Başka insan
sağlığına toksik etkisi vardır. Ağır
metaldir. Kurşun vücuda girdiğinde
işitme, sinir sistemi gibi yerlerde ne
yapar? bozukluğa sebep olmaktadır.
Kansızlık, mide arısı, böbrek ve beyin
iltihabı gibi durumlara sebep olur.
Belli bir miktar biriktikten sonra da
kansere sebep olabilmektedir. Hatta
şöyle ilginç bir durum vardır. Çanakkale
Savaşı'nda eee bizim mermiler birazcık
böyle şey kalitesiz mi diyeyim daha
farklı direkt kurşundan oluşuyor. Böyle
düşmana sıktığında adam ölmese bile
adamın vücudunda kaldığında kurşun
zehirlenmesine sebep oluyormuş. Ama bunu
bizimkiler bilerek yapmamış. Yani öyle
bir durum oluşmuş. Yani o yaralananların
da bir kısmı mesela bundan dolayı ölmüş.
Böyle ilginç bir durum da vardır. Cıva.
Cıva çok tehlikelidir ki dur bak benim
elimde az bir miktar var. Gerçekten az
bir miktar diyeyim. Şöyle yakından
göstereceğim. Bir dakika. Aha şurada.
Dur bakayım. Net lan. Heh. Şu mesela bak
burada bunun içerisinde civa var. Şöyle
az bir miktar cıva bulunuyor. Şöyle
sallayayım. Bak gördün mü? Tepesini
şöyle biraz daha yaklaştırayım. İşte şu
cıva sıvı haldeki metaldir. Bu nasıl bir
maddedir? Şöyle söyleyelim. DNA hasarına
sebep olabilmektedir. Özellikle sinir
sistemi üzerinde çok tehlikelidir ve
zehirlidir. Yani bunu buharını
soluduğunda ki ağzını böyle sıkı sıkı
kapatırım buharlaşmasın diye. Sonuçta
buharı da zehirlidir. Vücuda girdiğinde
de zehirlidir. Mesela özellikle
hamilelerde cenin ve bebek gelişimini
olumsuz yönde etkilemektedir. Maden
atıkları ve bunun gibi hava ve suya
karışıp da besin zincirinde de ne
yapmakta? İnsan vücuduna kadar
gelmektedir. Yani civalı atıkları. Bu
pillerde falan da var. cıvalı atıkları
doğaya bıraktığında önce ne oluyor? İşte
doğada çözünmeye başlıyor. Bitkiler bunu
alıyor. O bitkiler işte hayvanlar
tarafından yeniliyor. O hayvanı biz
yiyoruz veya bitkiyi de oradan yiyoruz.
Yani dolaylı olarak doğaya attığımız
civayı kendi vücudumuza geri almış
oluyoruz. Birikmesi de tehlikelidir.
Yani ne yapmak gerekiyor? Bunların
atıklarını da depolamak gerekiyor. Geri
dönüştürmek gerekiyor ki özellikle bu
şeyler vardır. Çok masum zannederiz ama
küçük böyle düğme piller vardır. Hap pil
falan diyorlar. Böyle saat pilleri.
Bunlar mesela cıva içermektedir. Onu
öyle ne alacak sanki bundan deyip
atmayın. Tehlikelidir. Karbondioksit ki
karbondioksit zaten atmosferde fazla
miktarda olduğunda sera etkisi küresel
ısınmaya sebep oluyor. Asit yağmuruna
sebep oluyor. Organik yapılı maddelerin
yanması sonucunda fosil yakıtlardan
bahsediyoruz genellikle. Yanması
sonucunda karbondioksit oluşmakta. Başka
ne var? Sera gazına oluşumuna sebep
oluyor ve küresel ısınmayı arttırıyor.
Asit yağmurlarına neden oluyor diyoruz.
fazla miktarda solunduğunda da yani
ölümle sonuçlanacak durumlar olabiliyor.
Karbonmoksit dediğimizde ise boğucu bir
gazdan bahsediyoruz. Ve şöyle bir şey
vardır. Belli bir miktar teneffüs
ettiğinde bunu önce uyku verir. Çok
tatlı bir uyku verir. Ama uyuduktan
sonra o son uykun olur. Bu soba gazı
zehirlenmeleri diyoruz ya işte soba gazı
zehirlenmelerinin baş sebebi budur.
Karbonmoksittir. Çünkü tam yanma
olmadığı için karbonmoksit ortama
yayılıyor. Ortama yayılınca insanların
uykusu geliyor ki genellikle de şöyle
bir şey oluyor. Yatmadan önce böyle
sobayı kömürle dolduruyorlar. Bu közde
kapandığı için oksijenle temas kesilince
karbonmoksit oluşmaya başlıyor. E oluşan
karbonmoksit de ne yapıyor dostum?
Ortama yayılıyor. Hele bir de ters
rüzgar eserse lodos falan filan e evin
içine yayılıyor. İnsanlar zaten uyuyor.
E karbonmoksit geldiğinde de onu
teneffüs etmeye başlıyor ve ondan sonra
o son uyku oluyor. Ne yazık ki bir daha
uyanamıyor. Mümkün mertebe buna dikkat
etmekte fayda var. İyi havalandırmak
gerekiyor ortamları. Özellikle sobalı
evlerde burada işte söylüyor. Beyin,
kalp gibi organlarda ve dokularda sinir
sisteminde bozukluklara sebep olur.
Yüksek seviyede karbon monoksite maruz
kalındığında komaya veya ölüme sebep
verebilmektedir. Soba gazı
zehirlenmesini tekrar söylüyorum. Azot
dioksit NO2. Bu asidik bir oksittir.
Suyla karışınca aside dönüştüğü için
asit yağmurlarına sebep olur. Zehirli
bir gazdır ve hava kirliliğine neden
olmaktadır diyoruz. Kükürt trioksit var
ki bu da asidik oksittir. Havadaki su
buharıyla birleşip aside dönüşür. Yani
asit yağmurlarına sebep olur. Yanıcı
olmayan ama zehirli bir gazdır. Onu da
bilmekte fayda var. İşte bu fabrika
bacalarından şundan bundan çıkan gazlar
neye dönüşüyor? Bu asitlere dönüşüyor ve
yeryüzüne yağarak ne yapıyor? Ağaçları
şunları bunları kötü etkilemiş oluyor.
Yani asit yağmuruna sebep olan
gazlarmış. Başka ne var? klor gazı var
ki klor gazı genel olarak zehirli bir
gazdır. Su arıtımında, havuzlarda,
kanalizasyonlarda dezenfektan olarak
kullanılmaktadır. Zehirli bir gazlık
insan sağlığına zararlıdır ve kanserojen
etkiye sebep olabilmektedir. Çevreye de
zararlı bir gazdır. Fakat bunun oluşumu
ile ilgili bir şey söyleyeyim. Evlerde
bunu oluşturabiliyoruz. Böyle bir risk
var. Nasıl var? O da şöyle var. Çamaşır
suyu ile tuz ruhunu karıştırdığında veya
çamaşır suyu ile asidik bir maddeyi
karıştırdığında klor gazı oluşmaktadır.
O klor gazı da zehirlidir. Evde temizlik
yaparken çamaşır suyuyla başka bir şeyi
sakın karıştırmayın. Tehlikelidir. Heh.
Şimdi geldik laboratuvar aletlerine.
Neler var laboratuvar aletlerinden? İlki
beher çözelti hazırlama, karıştırma,
ısıtma, kristallendirme işleminde
kullanılmaktadır. Yüksek ısıya
dayanıklıdır diyoruz. Aha da şu dostum.
Bak şöyle göstereyim sana. Şundan
bahsediyorum. Bu mesela işte beher. Bu
kaçlık behermiş? 100'lük behermiş. Bu
küçük yüksek ısıya dayanıklıdır. Bunlar
borcamdır. Bu yüksek ısıya dayanıklı.
Bunun içerisinde işte ısıtma işlemleri,
karıştırma işlemleri, kristallendirme
işlemlerini yapmaktayız. Bu boy boy. Bu
en küçük boylarından bir tanesi mesela.
İkincisi neymiş? Erlen Mayer. İlki
beherglastı bu. Erlen mayer çözelti,
hazırlama, saklama ve titrasyon
işleminde kullanılmakta. Koni biçiminde
diyoruz ki o da burada dostum. Bak işte
şundan bahsediyorum. Şöyle netleyecek
umarım. He bu da mesela böyle çözelti
hazırlamak için kullanıyoruz. Titrasyon
işlemi dediğimiz olay şu. Birazdan
söyleyeceğim. Büret diye bir alet var.
Bu değil ama bak büret şuna benzer.
Musluklu bir alet. Şu musluğu açarak
böyle içerisine sıvıyı döküp böyle
karıştırıyoruz. Bu işlem mesela
titrasyon işlemi burada kullanılmakta.
Dediğim gibi çözelti hazırlama titrasyon
işlemi saklama işlemlerinde
kullanılıyor. Koni biçiminde. Görüyor
musun? Buna ne diyoruz? Erlen mayer
diyoruz. Bir diğeri mezür ya da dereceli
silindir diyoruz. Saf sıvı ve çözelti
hacmini ölçme işlemlerinde kullanılır.
Çok hassas ölçüm yapmak için uygun
değildir. Çok hassas ölçümler için pipet
diye bir şey kullanacağız. Ama sonuçta
burada mezürle hacim ölçümü yapılabilir
mi? Kabaca yapılabilir. Yani çok böyle
çok ince hassas değerler gerekmeyen
durumlarda kullanabiliriz ki onu da
hemen göstereyim. Mezur dediğimiz şey şu
dostum. Şöyle bir yapı. Bunun da dediğim
gibi boy boy var. 1 litreliği var. İşte
yarım litreliği var. Çeşit çeşittir. Bu
küçüklerinden bir tanesi. Ne yapıyoruz?
İşte sıvıyı koyup hacmini ölçüp ona göre
kullanıyoruz. Bu da dereceli silindir.
Heh. Pipet. Pipet dedim ya hassas hacim
ölçümlerinde kullanılan sıvı ve sıvı
çözeltilerinin hacimlerini hacim
ölçümünde kullanılıyor. Hassas
ölçümlerde kullanılıyor. Pipet ki
göstermiştim bunu. Pipet şu işte. Şöyle
göstereyim. Pipet dediğim alet. Şöyle
netlesin bakayım. Heh. Şu mesela pipet
dediğimiz alet. Bunu kullanırken ne
yapıyorduk? Puar kullanıyorduk, değil
mi? Tepesine puhar takıyorduk. Hacmi
yani sıvıyı o şekilde çekiyorduk. Hacmi
o şekilde belirliyorduk. Döndüm buraya.
Deney tüpü laboratuvarda en çok
kırdığımız şeylerden bir tanesi. Çok
kullanıyoruz bunu. Çok amaçlı olarak
kullanılır. Genellikle yaklaşık olarak
100 dereceye dayanıklı cam malzemedir.
Yok çok yüksek sıcaklıklara gelemiyor
ama laboratuvarda bol miktarda
kullanmaktayız. Onu da istersen yakından
göstereyim. Şundan bahsediyorumuz. İşte
bu şey deney tüpü en çok kullanılan
şeylerden bir tanesidir laboratuvarda.
Bir diğeri havan. Genellikle porselen
havan kullanmaktayız ama camı da var.
Cam porselen çelik türleri
bulunmaktadır. Katı malzemeleri toz
haline getirmekte kullanılmaktadır diyor
ve işte farklı maddeleri birbiri
içerisinde ezmek için kullanılıyor. Onu
da göstereceğim. Bir saniye. Aha o da
burada. Şöyle yakına alalım. Havan
dediğimiz mesela bu porselen havan.
Şöyle bu iç kısmı biraz daha pütürlüdür.
Şununla mesela eze eze bu şekilde işlem
yapıyorsun. Toz haline getiriyorsun. Çok
da güzeldir, kullanışlıdır yani. Bir
diğeri balon joje. Balon joje belirli
derişimde çözeltilerin hazırlanıp
saklanmasında kullanılır. Boyun kısmında
çizgi vardır. O da hacmi belirtmektedir.
Hemen örneğimizi göstereyim sana. Şöyle
yaklaştım. Bu kaçlık? 250 mlrlik bir
balon joje. Bak balon joje. Bu böyle bir
şekle sahiptir. Uzun ince bir boynu
vardır. Çözelti saklamada kullanılır.
Bak kapaklı olduğu için saklanır. Şu
boyun kısmındaki çizgiyi göstermeye
çalışacağım. Bak gözüktü mü? Gözükmedi
tabii ki. Dur onu bir şekilde göstermem
lazım sana. Şurada bak. He gördün mü?
İnce bir çizgi var. Şurada çok ince bir
çizgi var. İşte oraya kadar
doldurduğunda bu 250 mlrlik oluyor. Eğer
şuradaki hacim neyse şu boynundaki
çizgiye kadar doldurduğunda o hacme
sahip oluyor. Böyle bir kaptır. Bu
şekilde kullanılır. Çözelti hazırlarız.
Çözelti saklarız. Bunun içerisinde. Bir
diğeri de spatül laboratuvar aleti.
Bunun bende o kadar çok çeşidi var ki
katı malzemeleri, toz halindeki
malzemeleri bir yerden bir yere koymak
için kullanırız. Genellikle plastik ve
metal olanları vardır. Bende böyle bir
sürü var. Şu şekilde çeşit çeşittir
bunlar. Böyle incesi, kalını böyle. Dur
birkaç tanesini çıkaracağım. Heh,
çıkarttım. Mesela bak şu spatül
dediğimiz olay şu. Bir tarafı çay
kaşığına benzer. Bir tarafı spatulaya
benzer. Bu işte katı malzemeyi böyle az
miktarda alıp kullanmakta eee şey
yaparız. İşte bunu kullanırız.
Kullanmakta kullanırız da saçma olur. Bu
da mesela uzun versiyonu. Onun birazcık
daha uzun olanı. Şöyle göstereyim. Bu da
böyle çay kaşığı gibi. Bir tarafı
spatula şeklinde mesela. Çok çok az
miktardakileri şey yapacaksan,
kullanacaksan. Onda da mesela bu var.
Bak görüyor musun? Ucu ne kadar küçük.
Diğer tarafına bak böyle incecik. Şöyle
göstereyim. İnce mesela çok az malzemeyi
de mesela böyle belki miligramlık
malzemeleri de bunlarla mesela alıyoruz.
Cımbız vardır. O da mesela şöyle
aletler. O zaten cımbızı bilmeyen yok da
işte bu da böyle çok hassas cımbızlardan
bir tanesi. Benim elimde bunların
hepsinden var. Laboratuvarı kurmak için
birçok malzemeyi aldım. Almaya da devam
ediyorum zaten. Hayalimi yapacağım
biliyorsunuz. Evet, devam edelim. Bir
diğer malzememiz ise büret. Büret eee
şöyle uzun ince bir aynı o pipet vardı
ya pipet gibidir ama daha uzununu düşün.
Biraz daha geniş uzun. Ucu musluklu bir
alettir bu. İnce cam bir borudur ve
ucunda musluk bulunur. Titrasyon işlemi
yani asit baz tepkimesinin damla damla
gerçekleştirilmesinde kullanılır. Şu an
göstereceğim şey büret değil ama
büreetin mantığını anlatmak için
gösteriyorum. Şu tepe kısmının böyle
daha geniş yukarıya doğru çıktığını
düşün. Şöyle şurada hani gözükmediği
yerden yapacağım. Şu var ya bak şu
musluğu çevirip sıvıyı böyle döküyor.
Damla damla buradan dökülüyor. Alta da
işte bunu koyuyor. Bu şekilde titrasyon
işlemini gerçekleştiriyor. Bret bunun
için kullanılan bir alettir. Bu büret
değil. Bu normal musluk. Ama ben hani
büreti tanıtmak için böyle şey hani
kafanda canlansın diye gösteriyorum.
Brüeti alamadım daha. Onu da alacağım.
Bir diğer malzememiz cam balon. Cam
balon. Çözelti, hazırlama, karıştırma,
kaynatma, damıtma işlemlerinde
kullanılır. Kimyasal reaksiyon
gerçekleştirilen bir malzemedir. O da
burada bir yerdeydi. Aha bunu da bu
tarafa koymuşum. Şeye balon joje'ye
benzer. Yan yana getireceğim zaten.
Şöyle balon joje benzemektedir. Ama bu
daha böyle bir tıknazdır. Görüyor musun?
Etine dolgun böyle toplu haldedir. Bu
işte damıtma işlemlerinde
kullanmaktadır. Çözelti hazırlamak
kullanılır. Başka reaksiyon
gerçekleştirme işlemlerinde bu cam
balonu çok kullanıyoruz. Bak büet şey ne
bili? E balon joje ve cam balon. Bak
farkını anladın mı? Uzun ince boyunlu.
Bu böyle toplu haldedir. Bunlar
birbirinden farklıdır. Cam balon. Bu da
balon joje. Tamam mı dostum? Kroze
dediğimiz böyle bardağa benzeyen şeydir.
Porselenden bir yapıdır ki çok yüksek
sıcaklıklara dayanır. Bazısı 1000 küsür
derecelere dayanabilmektedir. İçerisine
işte bir maddeyi koyarsın. Bu maddenin
işte şey yapılmasını, ısıyla
parçalanmasını, buharlaşmasını, kül
haline getirilmesinde falan
kullanılmaktadır. Böyle yüksek
sıcaklıktaki fırınlarda kullanırız bunu.
Atıyorum işte elinde ne var? Örnek
veriyorum altın ve bakır var. Bunları
karıştırdın. Alaşım yapmak istiyorsun.
İşte ne 22 ayar altın yapacaksın mesela.
İşte bu krozelerin içerisine
yerleştiriyor. İçinde eritilip daha
sonra işte şekillendiriliyor falan
filan. Bir diğer aletimizse neymiş? O da
şeymiş. termometre sıcaklık ölçümünde
kullanılır ki onun da orijinal
versiyonunu cıvalı termometre kolay
bulunan bir şey değildir. Bir tanesini
mesela bak buradaki bile kırmızı e özel
çözeltiyile hazırlanmış. Bendeki
orijinal cıvalı termometredir. Şöyle
göstereyim dostum. Bayağı bir hassastır
çünkü bunlar. Şöyle bir şeydir. Dur
bakayım netle. Bak cıva var burada.
Burada sıcaklık arttıkça ne oluyor?
Burada gösteriyor. Hassas bir şeydir.
Bayağı bir hassastır. Şu an mesela kaçı
gösteriyor. Neredesin la? Dur. Heh. Şu
anda aşağı yukarı dah soğuk tabii ki.
Yavaş yavaş ısınıyor işte 20 küsur
derecelerden 30'a doğru geliyor. Şu an
burası gerçeği bayağı bir sıcak da tabii
bu soğukta kaldığı için bayağı bir düşük
kalmış. Bu da işte benim şeyim
termometrem. Cıvalı termometrem. Başka
ne var? Ayırma hunisi. Bundan vardı. Bak
bundan vardı. Kırdım. E yenisini
alacağım. Yoğunlukları farklı sıvıları
ayırmakta kullanıyoruz ki onu şöyle
göstermek istiyorum. Bu şekil üzerinde
mesela zeytinyağı ve su var. Zeytinyağı
ve suyu aldığında su ne olur? Altta
kalır. Zeytinyağı da üstte kalır.
Zeytinyağı da üstte kalır. Şu musluğu
açtığında önce yoğunluğu büyük olan
buradan ayrılır. Sonra diğeri ayrılır.
İşte farklı yoğunluktaki birbirine
karışmayan sıvıları ayırmakta
kullandığımız bir şeydir. Alettir bu.
Başka ne var? Baget var. Karışım
hazırlarken karıştırma işleminde
kullanılmaktadır. Bu camdan olur ama
bende ilginç bir çeşidi var. Normalde az
bulunan bir çeşittir. Çok kullanmayı
tercih etmiyorum ama işte göstermek
istiyorum. Bu da şey işte baget. Bu
plastik baget olarak geçiyor. Çok
kullanılmaz aslında. Cam baget daha
sağlıklıdır yani daha iyidir. Bu da işte
çünkü bu çok sıcaklığa gelmeyecektir.
Isıya gelmeyecektir. Cam bagetler
vardır. Bende plastiği var mesela. Cam
bagette alsam iyi olacak. Ha bir diğeri
saat camı. Az miktarda katıları
kurutmak, ısıtmak işlemlerinde
kullanılan iç bükey bir yapıya sahiptir.
Onu da hemen göstereyim. O da şöyle bir
parça. Bak görüyor musun? İç bükey bir
görüntüye sahip. İşte içerisine
koyuyorsun şeyleri, katıları. Burada
kurutma işlemi yapıyorsun zaten. Bak
hala şey kalmış. Kirli kalmış. Bayağı
bir tozlanmış bu. Bunları bir ara
temizlesem iyi olacak. Sırada ne var?
İspirto ocağı var ki o öğrencimin
patlattığı şey. Bunun kalitesiz
versiyonuydu. O kavanozdan falan
yapılmış. Böyle değişikti. Ne oluyor
biliyor musun? Bak şurada bir fitil var.
Alttan şeyi alıyor. Ispirtoyu fitil
şuraya getiriyor. Burada yakıyor. Altta
işte üstte de ısıtma işlemini
gerçekleştiriyorsun. E böyle bir
sistemdir. Onun üzerine de mesela saç
ayağı falan koyuyorlar. Üzerine de şey
mesela beheri koyuyor. Isıtma işlemini
yapıyor. Sonra ne var? Huni var. Süzme
işlemlerini kullanıyor. İçerisine süzgeç
kağıdı koyuyoruz ki o da var elimde.
Bunun plastik versiyonunu şu an
getirdim. Cam versiyonları da vardı.
Şöyle bir şey. Dur netlesin. Heh. Şundan
bahsediyorum. İçerisine süzgeç kağıdı
koyuyorsun. Katı sıvı karışımını buradan
döktüğünde katı üstte kalıyor. Sıvı
alttan dökülüyor. İşte klasik huni işte.
Daha neyini anlatayım bunun? Evet. Şimdi
bakalım bunlarla ilgili örneklerimiz
varmış. Diyor ki, "Bir kap içerisinde
derişik H2CO4 sulu çözeltisi
bulunmaktadır. Bu sulu çözeltiden 2 ml
almak için X cam malzemesi kullanılıyor.
2 ml. Çok az bir miktar değil mi? 2 ml.
O zaman hassas bir ölçümden
bahsediyoruz. Daha sonra bu şey H2CO4
çözeltisi ince uzun boyunlu. İnce uzun
boyun dediği anda benim aklıma ne geldi?
Balon joje geldi. E neymiş? Boyun
kısmında çizgi tamam balon jaşe garanti.
Y cam malzemesi içine konulup üzerine su
ilave edilerek saklanıyormuş. Çok güzel.
Buna göre diyor ki hazırlanan işte x ve
yam şey malzemeler nedir diye soruyor.
Şimdi kullanılan malzemeler nelerdir
biliyor musun? 2 mlitrelik bir şey
alıyorum ölçüm için. Malzeme alıyorsam
yani şey sıvı alıyorsam hassas ölçümle
almam gerekiyor. Pipeti kullanabilirim
değil mi? Pipet. Eyvallah. He şu var
hocam. Çok böyle küçük bir şeyde mezürde
kullanamaz mıyım? dereceli silindir.
Hadi diyelim. Kullandın. Tamam. Hadi onu
da kabul ettik. Normalde 2 mlreyi gene
hassas ölçmen lazım. Hadi kullandık
diyelim. Ama ince boyunlu boyun kısmında
çizgi olan çözelti sakladığımız kap
neydi? Balon jojeydi. O yüzden cevabımız
ne olacaktır? E seçeneği olacaktır.
Burada diyor ki yukarıdaki laboratuvar
malzemelerinden hangilerinin kullanım
alanı doğru verilmiştir? Bakalım. Bu
ilki Erlen Mayer yani çözelti hazırlama,
saklama ve titrasyonda kullanılıyordu.
Doğru. İkincisi neydi? dereceli
silindirdi. Saf sıvı hacimlerinin
ölçümünde kullanılıyordu. Evet. Üçüncüsü
de neydi? Ayırma hunisiydi. Yoğunlukları
farklı sıvıları heterojen sıvı
karışımlarını ayırmakta kullanılıyordu.
O zaman bu da doğru. O zaman hepsi
doğrudur. Açıklamalar doğrudur. Cevap da
E seçeneğidir. Şimdi bakalım genel
sorularımız var bununla ilgili. Yani
konuyu şöyle tarayacak sorular da var.
Diyor ki yukarıdaki görsellerde verilen
maddelerle ilgili aşağıda verilen
ifadelerden hangisi yanlıştır diyor. Hım
bakalım. Şimdi üçüncüsü ney? F2O3 pas.
Yani bu bir bileşik. Bileşik formülle
gösterilir. Birincisi ne? Demir.
Element. O da sembolle gösterilir. O
zaman üç formülle bir sembolle
gösterilir. Doğru. Üçü de homojen
yapılıdır. Saf maddeler homojen
yapılıdır. Elementler ve bileşikler saf
madde olduğu için homojen yapılıdır. O
yüzden doğrudur. Diyor ki bir atomik
element olduğu için doğru. İkincisi P4
diyor. O da moleküler yapılıdır. Doğru.
Birden fazla atom bir arada bulunuyor.
Diyor ki 1 ve 2 element tek cins atom
içeriyor. Doğru. Üçüncüsü birden fazla
cins ve formüle sahip. Bu da bileşiktir.
O yüzden bu da doğrudur. Diyor ki 2 ve 3
saf madde bir saf olmayan maddedir. Y
elementte bileşikte saf maddedir. Yani
verilenlerin hepsi saf maddedir. Bu
yanlıştır. Cevap da E seçeneğidir.
Yukarıdaki laboratuvar malzemesi ile
ilgili bu neydi? Bir beher glastı. Beher
glass çözelti hazırlama ve ısıtma
işleminde kullanılıyordu. Doğru.
Erlenmeer. Hayır. O neydi? İnce uzun şey
pardon ince uzun demişim. Böyle koni
şeklinde olandı. diyor ki yüksek
sıcaklığa dayanıklı camdan üretilir.
Evet, ısıtma işlemi yaptığımıza göre
öyle olmak zorunda. Cevap 1 ve 3 olur.
Yani D seçeneği. Diyor ki, "Aşağıda
verilen çalışmalardan hangisi bir
simyacıya ait olamaz?" Simyacılar ne
yapıyordu? Deneme yanılmayla
çalışıyordu, değil mi? Bakalım şimdi.
Bitkilerden tedavi amaçlı bir ilaç yapma
vardı, değil mi? Eski çağlardan nane,
limon kabuğu falan filan yapıyordu.
Elektroliz ile hidrojen gazı elde etme.
Elektrik o ne? O nasıl bir şey diyecek
simyacı değil mi? Daha bulunmamış bir
şeyden bahsediyoruz. Hidrojen gazı elde
ediyor. Elektroliz var mı o zaman?
Olmaz. Gitti. Zaç yağı üretme. Zatç yağı
H2SO4. Evet. Ne yapmıştı? Cabir bin
Hayyan üretmişti. Doğrudur. Diyor ki,
"Yağ ve kül suyunu karıştırıp sabun elde
etme." Sabun da simyacılar zamanında
bulunmuştu. Evet. "Bitki köklerinden
boyar madde yapma yine onların işidir."
Yani burada simyacıya ait olmayacak iş B
seçeneğindeki elektrolizdir. Diyor ki,
"Ebubekir Errazi'nin kimya bilimine çok
katkısı olmuştur." Evet, olmuştur. Ne
yapmıştı? Antman diyorduk bu adama. Yani
karınca asidi üretme. O yüzden bu tamam.
Karınca asidini üretirken karıncaları
damıtmıştı. Tıp alanında çalışmalar.
Evet. Simyayı tıpta kullanmıştı.
Doğruydu. İmbik kullanarak zaç yağı elde
etme. Hayır. Bu Cabir bin Hayyan'a ait
bir özellikti. Gitti. Cevap bir. Cevap 1
ve 2. Yani C seçeneği. Cevap dedim la.
Yukarıdaki kimya disiplinlerinden
hangilerinin özellikleri doğrudur?
Biyokimya. Biyo. Biyoloji canlılarla
ilgili. O zaman canlıların yapısında
gerçekleşen kimyasal tepkimeleri
inceler. Tak. Doğrudur. Organik kimya
karbon temelli bileşikleri inceliyordu.
O yüzden bu da doğrudur. Fizikokimya
kimyasal tepkimelerdeki fiziksel
olayları inceliyordu. Yani fiziksel
faktörlerin kimyasal tepkimelere
etkisini incelemektedir. O zaman hepsi
doğru oldu. Cevap da E seçeneği. Geldik
ünitemizin son sorusuna. Diyor ki,
"Aşağıda verilen bileşik formülü yaygın
adı eşleştirmelerinden hangisi
yanlıştır?" "CH3COOH. Bu sirke asidiydi.
Karınca asidi demiş. Hayır. O HCOOH'tır.
Bu yanlış. Kireç taşı kalsiyum karbonatı
doğru. Sut kostik NaOH'tı. Potas kostik
de KOH'tı. O yüzden sut kostik doğru. HC
ile tuz ruhuydu. Doğru. Nah coi neydi?
Yemek sodasıydı. Nah sana yemek şeklinde
kodlayabiliriz. O yüzden bu da doğrudur.
Biz yanlışı bulduk. Cevabımız A
seçeneğidir. Evet güzel insan.
Böylelikle ne yapmış olduk? Kimya bilimi
ünitesini bitirmiş olduk ki elimden
geldiğince laboratuvar malzemelerinin
hepsini sana görsel olarak ifade etmeye
çalıştım. Günlük hayatta yaşanabilecek
durumlardan bahsetmeye çalıştım.
başımdan geçen olaylardan bahsettim.
Yani burası sınav için lazım olmasa bile
günlük yaşantın için lazım olan şeyler
içeriyordu. O yüzden beni dinlediğin
için teşekkür ederim. Buraya kadar
geldiysen helal olsun sana dostum. Şimdi
ne yapıyorsun? Bunlarla ilgili soru
çözmen gerekiyor. Çünkü burayı
pekiştirmeden geçersen olmaz
unutabilirsin. O yüzden hemen soru
çözmen gerekiyor. Sonra soru çözümünü
izle. Ondan sonra da notlarını al.
Kenara unuttuğun şeyleri de bir kenara
yaz. Sonra bu konu tamam olsun dostum.
Evet. zeduva.com'a bakmayı kesinlikle
ihmal etme. Çünkü bu konunun PDF'ini
oradan ulaşacaksın. Diğer hocalarımızın
çalışmalarına oradan ulaşacaksın.
zedua.com sizin için uğrak yeri olmalı.
Her şeyimiz orada dostum. Onun dışında
kitabı alıp destek olursan da çok mutlu
olurum. Özellikle de zeduva.com
üzerinden aldığında daha fazla destek
olabileceksin. Ve onun dışında destek
olma yöntemi arıyorsan da kanala abone
olup yorum yapıp beğenirsen de çok mutlu
olurum değerli dostum. O zaman ne
diyoruz? İki fosfor asit. Kimya bu kadar
basit. Bir sonraki derste görüşmek
üzere. Hoşça kalın.